welcome to
another dr sadler's honest reviews this
is a video series in which i review
mostly recent books having to do with
practical philosophy broadly construed
so it includes self-help
it includes personal development
leadership business organization
but also things that are straight out
philosophy
as well and the book that i'm reviewing
this time
uh is being better stoicism for a world
worth living in by kai whiting and
leonidas
constatakos so there's a couple things
to say about this before
i jump into it first of all this is a
very timely review this book has
just come out as a matter of fact i've
got one of the
review copies and kai in fact
weighed in and said you got a copy
before i did
as the author so that that's always kind
of cool
the other thing i will say is kai is a
personal friend and colleague as is leo
and it's always nice when you're
reviewing
somebody's works that you're connected
with
if you don't have to have too many bad
things to say
and that that's the case because this is
quite good
i do highly recommend this
short book and i'll tell you why in
just a few
i always like to begin these reviews by
highlighting the three
s's a summary talk about the style talk
about the structure of the work
that way those of you who are watching
or listening know exactly what you're
getting into
right away and i guess the first thing i
would say in terms of summarizing is
that the title
not every book necessarily tells you
exactly what it's about in the title
this one does
being better the goal is not just
feeling better but to actually be
be a better person become a better
person become a better you
and stoicism for a world worth living
and the book is definitely about
stoicism that's
front and center every single page but a
world worth
living in so it's it's not just looking
at
you your relationships it's looking at
how you fit into
the wider world and how other people do
as well and how stoicism
can can fit in with that and support it
so that's
probably a good summary of the work
i would say and
there's a lot of nice nice references
here that we could we could go into
later on it's written in a very
conversational style there
are a number of chapters
nine of them actually and each chapter
is is you know fairly
short you could sit down and read it
in the space of anywhere from like maybe
15 to 30 minutes depending on how
quickly you're going through it
each one is doing something you know
that the title
indicates and i would say as far as the
structure goes as well
each of these is going to introduce a
key stoic
idea tell you about some stoic
personalities that develop this and
how it fit into their life bring in some
examples
of people who are not specifically
stoics very often much closer to us
in time and then each chapter concludes
with you know a little bit of uh stuff
to think about so for example
chapter uh two it's musconius's
questions because it's talking about
musonius rufus
and i'll give you an example of this one
so it says look around
what is no longer serving you because
it's getting in the way of your capacity
to think
and act virtuously is it a possession if
it is why are you keeping it
is it a friendship is it a job why do
you value it is there a way of making
these things work better for you and
your family so it's not just a question
it's actually a set of open-ended
questions
which you could use for journaling this
could also be used for
discussions between people who are
reading the the text together and that's
basically the way
each of the chapters is set up it's not
a particularly long book
there is a nice acknowledgements uh
appendix
a lot of notes which is quite good
and a very good index as well and then a
little bit about the authors
so you know each of these these chapters
is giving you something to work with
um on very early on in the book
they say in many ways this book is a
contemporary version of zeno's presence
at the painted porch we wrote it for all
those who as they walk through the
proverbial public
square believe they could live the good
life and are willing to put in the work
to achieve it
so you know they're saying you know
we're doing
something similar to what zeno is doing
at the the stoa poi chile the painted
porch that the stoa is named after
we're giving you some things to think
about these aren't necessarily
the entirety of stoicism
but we're going to zero in on some of
the key things and you make of them
what you will so i think that's probably
enough to say about
the 3s's style structure summary
let's talk about some key ideas that are
put forth
in the work first as i mentioned the
title being better right so
in the course of the work this is
something i actually think is a strong
point so i'm probably going to return to
this again
there's this idea that it's not about
feeling better
it's about actually being better so
you know self-help can be great but
stoicism shouldn't be reduced down to
self-help or sound bites or you know
whatever is going to make us
feel better about ourselves it really
does involve
becoming a better person becoming a
better you
becoming more fully who you as a human
being
are and i think that they've very
effectively
not just captured that idea but driven
it home
in point after point after point when we
get into the
the other main ideas of the work
um so if you know if you look at the
chapter titles right
i think that gives us a lot to work with
um the promise of the good life is
chapter one well what is happiness what
is
the good life that's that's something
that the stoics devoted a lot of
discussion to
and you know kai and leo are unpacking
that
virtue as a way forward
okay that's really great because you
know in the organization
it's very tempting to begin with what
they talk about in chapter three the
dichotomy of control know what's in your
control and what's not that's a very
popular way to introduce people to
stoicism i think
hitting on and highlighting the the
cardinal virtues
justice wisdom courage temperance which
are absolutely central
to stoicism any real stoicism is really
the way to go
to put those out there as front and
central to
make the dichotomy of control something
that's useful but not the totality
of stoicism chapter four is called
recognize
luck and that's an interesting one
because
as they point out strictly speaking from
the stoic perspective there is no such
thing as
luck in the sense of complete randomness
at least for classic
stoics and we we are responsible to some
degree
for what we make of our positions but we
do have to recognize that
nobody really starts out in exactly the
same position as everybody else it's not
like we have a tabula
raza for our you know ourselves and our
culture
and our position in society so that's
that's a useful set of themes
um no one is an island that's you all
know that
you know catchphrase right no man is an
island
um and that that's quite true where
they go with that is not just to talk
about our social nature
but also to talk about something that
they began
approaching in the previous chapter
about luck namely that nobody's
self-made either
you you are who you are because of
drawing upon
all the contributions that so many other
people
have made and so you know if we want to
be wise if we want to be
just you know those virtues then we
actually have to take that into account
and quit pretending like people you know
captains of industry are self-made and
therefore
we should just go along with that and
what we see there is an emphasis on the
virtue
of justice the next chapter chapter six
is called put people in circles not
boxes
a nice slogan and you might say well
what's the difference you know round box
square box
okay so putting people in boxes is just
categorizing them
putting people in circles is very
important from a stoic perspective
because these circles
associated with heracles the the stoic
are these concentric uh
you know ways in which we grasp who's
closer to us who's further away and the
stoics say we should actually care about
everybody in these circles this is part
of stoic cosmopolitanism
and kai and leo are extending this
as well to the world of animals plants
the environment
so that's quite important they approach
the
the always vexing question of what it
means to live
in accordance with nature as well in
chapter eight so there's a lot of
interesting discussion of those themes
there
and then it concludes with this well on
the way to a life transform the goal of
this book
is not to like just preach at you and do
this do that
but to give you some insight and some
ideas that then you can choose if you
want to
to work your way to a better life
and that means a commitment to being
part of
a world that you're doing something to
make better
so i think that that's actually um
a good summary of the chapters there's
i would say another thing about this
book is there's a heavy emphasis
as you do see with some other
contemporary um
you know i'm going to teach you about
stoicism literature
in talking about examples introducing
you to
people and the the people that are
coming up are really falling into two
main classes there's a little bit of
overlap in the reference to
uh you know the admiral stockdale the
fighter pilot who got shot down
spent time in a vietnamese prison camp i
suppose you could also say there's a
little bit of overlap in the reference
to victor frankl the
originator of logotherapy and that he
draws on the stoics but for the most
part
what we get are the ancient stoics
with the inclusion of somebody else
who's
not a stoic per se but certainly had a
lot of connections with them and that's
that's cicero and so who do we get well
zeno the
founder of stoicism cleanthes chrysippus
uh musonius rufus epictetus cato
marcus aurelius cicero
as i mentioned um peniteus and
posidonius these middle stoics
feyrus who we we often don't talk a lot
about
because we don't know that much about
him and they try to reconstruct a
biography of him here and then of course
seneca right so there's a lot of
references to the classic stoics
and part of the idea here is to not try
to
summarize the entirety of their works
heracles by the way also gets mentioned
but to cull out what is going to be
particularly useful for the reader in
this
then there's all these discussions of
many
other people as well most of whom are
from
the 20th or 21st century
so you know the first set that that's
being contraposed here
is pat tillman and
catherine um uh
green right um here we go catherine
gunn sorry and they're both
people that have to do with the iraqi
the recent you know iraq
ii war on different sides in certain
respects and and there we're going to
get to that as an important point later
on
then we have a contrast between rosa
parks
and claudette column both of whom are
engaging in similar actions of resisting
segregation
a little bit later on alex zarnati
who i didn't actually know the story of
until i i read this he was a a uh
driver who man went through a lot of
challenging difficult circumstances i'm
not going to tell you too much about
what they're doing then there's others
as well who are coming up nick hanover
dan price hamdi
um
all of whom have to do with you could
say
business practices business settings
many of many of the the discussions here
are focusing not just on like profiles
and courage which you often see but
being motivated by justice being
motivated by wisdom
um who else do we have
um we have here we go on
towards the end of the book um
a very interesting thing uh having to do
with
trying to call
the invasive burmese pythons in the
everglades
tom rahil organized this group called
the swamp apes that leo
actually has participated in so these
are all
i'm not going to go over what leo
and and kai are doing with these but
let's say this each of them is being
used
not to say well this person was a stoic
but to say the kind of stuff that
they're doing
really aligns well with what
the stoics themselves preached so we can
we can look at them as examples of what
a contemporary stoic would be like today
and and multiply these by many others
and i i think that that's a
an interesting approach there is one
other key idea that i do want to
hit on that made me take a pause for a
moment
and say oh you know are they right about
this
are they wrong about this and it's
there's a phrase that i wanted to bring
up here we go
so
in in talking about um serious
and agus and cleomenes two spartan kings
[Music]
here's what what they say zeno and ly
kyrgyz shared one fundamental thing in
common
both had consulted the oracle of delphi
and had sub
subsequently lived lives worthy of her
advice
and then he says although these two
leaders lived 500 years apart
the oracle had shared with them the same
egalitarian vision built on a bedrock of
virtues
held together by mindful discipline and
austerity and when i when i read that
first i was like
wow this i think this is steering things
a little bit too anachronistically
uh you know saying that there's an
egalitarianism
to you know an egalitarian vision built
on a bedrock of virtues
and then after i thought about it a
little bit more
i said no actually these guys are right
about that
now the the traditional societies
in which virtue ethics was being put
forth
always a minority of people actually
practicing at doing it
they were stratified societies and they
they did have a lot of class
distinctions wealth distinctions
prestige distinctions so they weren't
egalitarian in that respect and when you
think about sparta you don't think of an
egalitarian
society either but virtue ethics really
is egalitarian
because it says anybody can practice
and develop the virtues and by the way
those people who are rich those people
who are powerful
they probably don't deserve the riches
or power that they have because they're
not actually
virtuous and so i think that this
actually is
quite right the the the notion that any
one of us
can improve our minds can develop the
you know uh the virtue of wisdom can can
develop
uh justice and enact justice in how we
relate ourselves to our you know
immediate surroundings the people that
we're engaged with
other people in many other places the
environment
pick whatever you want that all of us
can develop and practice
courage or fortitude that all of us can
you know do something in terms of
temperance i think they're right about
that
and so it's kind of an interesting point
to close
on when we think of the key ideas of
this work
i would say that that is one of the
underlying messages throughout the work
any one of us
could be like the people that they're
putting forth as examples
but we have to do the work
and put in the time and think things
through
in order to figure out what our role is
and
actually practice it
so i think there are a lot of good
points to this
this short book i'm going to just run
through them fairly quickly i think it's
very well thought
out kai and leo clearly put a lot of
time and discussion into what would be a
good
book to reach the ordinary person who
likes to read and maybe doesn't know
that much about stoicism
but also write a book that could be
interesting for those of us who've been
studying it for for quite a long time
and practicing it
so that's one good point i really think
that they do a great job
in highlighting the nature
the scope the meaning and the
application
of the virtues that's a really important
point and that connects it back to
classical stoicism i think
if we lose the virtues we actually lose
stoicism so they haven't done that and
highlighting justice
is is really central expanding that
to not just stoic cosmopolitanism being
concerned with you know everybody else
in the world
but saying uh we
can't just write off animals plants
the environment we really do need to
think about this not just for future
human generations
but also for the ecosphere that we
inhabit so they're bringing a lot of you
know
sustainability ideas into this
sustainability by the way isn't just
about you know
environment it's also about sustainable
economic practices it's also about
promoting all sorts of other things
connected to it
as as well so you know
they they are really bringing those
robust perspectives in here and i think
that's that's something that's needed
in contemporary stoic literature all too
often
the environment gets the last chapter
and that's about it
that's not happening in this
so we can talk about you know like an
unavoidability of
being concerned about the world
community
thinking about economic justice thinking
about
you know key ideas like you know minimum
wage
or how you know who we
prioritize and privilege in terms of
policies all of those can figure into
this and they give you a few examples
including among these people that
they're holding out as
exemplars you know if you have a company
you don't have to buy
into the trickle-down theory of
economics you can actually
you know change the way your company
works so everybody gets paid a decent
living wage that's that's
one prime example here another thing
that i really liked about the book
is and again i think this is a little
bit different than the way
many people in the present approach
stoicism so there's a little bit of a
digression and
maybe even a little bit of a rant but
there's in all these stoic forums
there's people are saying
what's the stoic position on this what's
the stoic position on this
and the answer from uh people who don't
really know
is usually well it's this or it's this
and they might throw in a quote the
answer from the experts is usually well
it depends right and this highlights
the need to use the virtue of prudence
so you know in respect of the iraq war
right
early on in it they have this as i
mentioned a great discussion
with two different people pat tillman
who goes off the fight
in the the war right he leaves a
pro you know football contract and
joins goes to afghanistan gets gets
killed over there
and then we have catherine gunn a
british translator who leaked
top secret memo from the nsa
because it represented a request for
assistance in blackmailing or bribing
the
six non-permanent un security council
members they're officially on two
different sides of the war right
but they're both acting with justice
they're both acting with courage they're
both
exemplifying what a stoic ought to do so
a lot of it
a lot of what what is the stoic position
on this
it does involve some you know paying
attention to the specifics the
particulars of the situation
it doesn't relativize everything as a
matter of fact it makes it even
more rigorous great example of this is
where they're talking about the virtues
and how to apply this to eating
right so they were talking about you
know whether they should um uh
choose dairy or or not you know they're
they're looking at plant-based diets
um and they talk about this early on in
in the first chapter
courage we recognize it takes guts to
confront governments and corporations
over how dairy products are sourced
right justice we take the time to
research and deeply consider how and to
what extent industrialized dairy
production
is linked to forced migration and
ecosystem deterioration right so big
very big picture
stuff self-control leo and i like the
taste of milkshakes and dairy ice cream
so maintaining a dairy-free life takes a
certain amount of discipline or
self-control
wisdom leo and i try to learn about what
we eat since we make decisions about
food every day
and then you notice though after
discussing this they say leo and i don't
restrict our food choices because we
derive pleasure
in being picky awkward or sanctimonious
we don't do it because we want to take a
box or be well regulated within a
certain
vegetarian or vegan community we don't
do it to impress the neighbors or to
prove to ourselves
how disciplined we are choosing not to
do something requires discipline but if
building discipline were the goal we'd
join or rejoin the army
avoiding dairy is one small way we try
to live out stoic
values and principles by fostering a
better
world but then they also say what do we
do when we're at somebody's house and
and they have this stuff so he says even
though leo and i
choose not to drink cow's milk in an
ideal situation
because of the unjust way it's produced
commercially there is no stoic
argument to support the idea that
drinking dairy milk is always bad
deciding to be gracious
polite guests is one situation that
calls for
flexibility especially when refusing
milk or milk products might seem rude
or could embarrass our hosts and
actually one of the people that they
discuss in here
is the founder of chobani yogurt right
so
you know i think this is a really great
point and that's one of the things i
really like about the book this this
sort of stress
on the need to cultivate and use
prudence that
it's not so simple as finding the stoic
solution to everything
and then just practicing that it's a
continual process of thinking things out
and oftentimes having
dialogue with other people so
those are the things that i think are
are strong points of the work
are there any things that i found
problematic about the work
problematic in the sense of like i'm
going to critique it
actually no i think it's a it's a pretty
good book and i
i recommend it i will say there are some
things where
it's not so much that there's there's
anything wrong
i just would have liked to have seen
maybe you know more more content
in in the work i think what what they're
doing is really great
it's the sort of thing where you're like
this is really good i would
i would have liked to have seen a lot
more
because i imagine it would be along the
same lines and and you know more of the
good stuff is is even better so so that
if you want to call that a criticism you
can call it a criticism
um the book is a little bit expensive
for
the size of the book you know it's 1695
usd for
the soft cover uh in a book that's a
hundred and
uh okay so 162 pages including the notes
and stuff like that
then again as they put in the back it's
from new world library and they
like they said we're a socially and
environmentally aware company
so we print our books a soy based ink on
100
post consumer waste recycled paper we
power our offices with solar energy
and you know so maybe it's it's actually
not that expensive when you take into
account
the fact that they're not using all of
the
shortcuts and cheap stuff including
labor
to manufacture books that so many other
people
are doing so you know maybe
maybe again something that that i
shouldn't be
complaining about um and you know
there really isn't anything else i can i
can
talk about as problematic except for
one passage that i myself kind of agree
with and like
but i think that some other people might
have a few problems with so
this is towards the end of the book in
the very last chapter
they say we're talking about the journey
towards eudaimonia or happiness and they
say as we break cycles of destructive
thoughts we open up enough
mental space to pay attention to an
altogether subtler
sound the whisper of the logos which
pervades all elements of life and
mandates what excellent behavior
consists of
like spherus xeno and countless other
stoics we might not hear the logo speak
to us straight away
however as long as we willingly do our
part for the common good
we will be able to envision our destiny
we will be able to transform our
personal life and the lives of others
including those of animals
in such a way that it gives us a sense
of inner stillness
speaking personally leo and i do not
experience this state of being all the
time
or even every day but we do feel it
increasingly often and we have stoicism
to thank for it um so what what should
we make of this is this kind of woo-woo
stuff you know a little bit too new-agey
i don't think so i think there it
depends on how you're going to
interpret this call of the logos um
i don't think it has to be uh
turned into something that's you know
kind of silly uh new agey
stuff i think that we could talk about
this is like you know just a growing
awareness of how we're connected to
other things
progress and virtue progress in in you
know
exterporating the vices connections with
other people
but you know that that sort of language
which they don't indulge in very much
could be off-putting to some people i i
guess
um but it happens at the end and it's
just a you know
one last thing and i would say it's
thought provoking so
again not something really that
problematic maybe even
a maybe it belongs in the strong points
of the work
section
my final thoughts so i i recommend this
book
um even for people who are well versed
in
in stoicism who you know read a lot of
the literature
and are practicing it i think that they
can get something
out of reading this and for a beginner i
think that what we have here
is a new addition to a
rather select company of really good
introductory works on stoicism
as a matter of fact if your goal is to
pick out
you know examples people if you want an
example based book
this is probably the one that you want
not the
others that are out there that make
implausible cases for people being
stoics who aren't really stoics
this is a very careful discussion
of that and it's you know very
informative um i i do like these
questions
in the back i think this could be a
great book for
it not just introducing people to
stoicism like you give this to somebody
but maybe for stoic fellowship groups or
other
classes seminars this this actually
could be a great book to recommend
so i i highly recommend it to you i'm
always happy
when you know people who i'm personally
connected with
if they send me something that it turns
out well so i have to say bad stuff
about it
and that definitely is the case for
being better stoicism for a world worth
living in
leo and kai put together a really solid
book here
you